so i want to kind of wrap this all
together
we we we heard from pompeo we've been
infiltrated by china sure joe biden's
rate his approval ratings are in the
trash he needs some kind of combat so he
points at russia because he knows russia
has no real threat
and he doesn't care about china or at
the very least he wants china to succeed
in the media remember in washington dc
in in remember the first impeachment
trial russia is like you know they i
want to call the 1980s and get get their
foreign policy back russia is considered
a 50 times bigger enemy than the chinese
communist party and one of the reasons
the money the chinese county's party has
spread all over town with the
journalists and all that russia is
a zero okay it is in a demographic
despot and it's pro don't get me wrong
they're bad guys run by the kgb with
lots of nuclear weapons okay and and and
they've got troops but this situation in
ukraine
is a european situation that they force
it on us
and and to do it on the e on the uh
commemoration of pearl harbor
right i think is i think is
extraordinary for him to do that let me
pull up this story look at the exact
quote here we have this from mediaite
gop senator floats u.s troops on the
ground and nuclear strike against russia
quote i would not rule that out senator
roger wicker of mississippi told neil
cavuto on tuesday the u.s shall keep
should keep all options available when
dealing with a potential russian
aggression against ukraine that even
includes a first use a preemptive
nuclear strike
that senator appeared on fox news hours
of the teleconference between biden and
putin quote
senator some of your republican
colleagues think that we should have
troops in the region they never
delineate exactly how many or that
they'd be utilized in an outright
confrontation with russia over ukraine
but their mere presence would be
effective what do you think of that i'll
tell you this neil said wicker i would
not rule out military action i think we
start making a mistake making a mistake
when we take options off the table so i
would hope the president keeps that
option on the table cavuto presses what
does military action mean he says well
military action military action could
mean that we stand off with our ships in
the black sea and we reign destruction
on russian military capability it could
mean it could mean that we participate
and i would not rule that out i would
not rule out american troops on the
ground he added we don't rule out first
use nuclear action we don't think it
will happen but there's certain things
in negotiations if you're going to be
tough you don't take off the table and
so i think the president should say that
everything is on the table
do you know steve um
the current power uh uh uh how do i hide
about this question um the web the
nuclear bombs we used in world war ii
do you know how many times stronger a
modern nuclear uh icbm is
1250 times more powerful a multiple
independently targeting re-entry vehicle
merv can drop 12 payloads from one icbm
it is laughable how insane that
destruction would be from one how many
does russia have they got what like 50
000 the us has what 25
this is the type of loose talk there's
one thing about negotiating and leverage
this is the type of when you actually
put on the table a first strike
over ukraine
this country is going to go to war over
eastern ukraine yeah what is russia this
is is what we're going to do in a
killing field in world war ii what 15
million died on the way when the nazis
went through and 12 million died on the
way back right
and they were fighting for each side you
couldn't tell who was fighting for whom
no this is
think about it for a second
if people had a belly fall of iraq in
afghanistan in 20 years in in the great
deplorable sons and daughters who fought
there and my daughter was after west
point went to iraq she deployed to iraq
and i can tell you as a parent
you know how little power you have in
life when you're praying every night
that they just come home in one piece
think about it for a second just after
extracting ourselves from there because
the american people said no more told
the elites you know and he did a
terrible job of getting out but we've
got to get out of saying president trump
want to do from day one
to know that they could be having a
conversation on a guy at a high level in
the senate that's been briefed a
republican and you can put on the table
combat troops and first strike nuclear
what are we talking about yeah that's
absolutely insane and before the show
started when we were talking about
ukraine i compared it to
uh europe's own kind of afghanistan
there's no winning or losing in in
ukraine it's only death especially when
you look at the larger history of what
happened there and today the ukrainian
government had a military parade the
ukrainian defense minister said that
this is going to lead to a bloody
massacre he's warning europe about 5
million refugees and he's not wrong
russia is making a very strong stance
here they're saying that they want a
legal guarantee that ukraine will never
join nato or become a base for weapons
that can target russia and they are
saying very strongly that they will
guarantee this themselves if they have
to they don't want to there's a two-hour
call with between biden and putin who's
of course relationships are very
tethered especially after biden started
attacking him publicly but there's also
plans for future talks luckily luckily
we're still in the phase of diplomacy
and we need more of that
far be it for me
to go back to hunter biden but it
shouldn't be lost on people that biden's
you know gig with barisma that whole
nightmare right with the russian thing
these guys have been skimming money off
the crooks in ukraine for decades okay
the clinton foundation the clinton
global initiative they've been out there
with their handout with these guys you
can't trust any of them a pox on all
their houses and the american people
cannot be sucked in to what brussels
brussels have been forcing this raheem
kassam's done some incredible reporting
he was there back in 15 i think when
they had the color revolution or 13 when
they had the color i was there as well
exactly so yeah so my point is you've
been there yeah why are we in 2021 with
all the problems we had and we just
extracted ourselves out of here that now
we're talking about an active deployment
when we got our hands full no to the
bite administration in that pencil neck
j sullivan you got enough problems show
me you have a plan in the south china
sea and around taiwan because if we lose
taiwan you're not going to get a ford
f-150 for five years okay
i want to pull this up from wikipedia
roger wicker is on the senate committee
on armed services
that's the biggest of the bill that's
the armed services committee right
because yeah you have the pascacoola
naval base you know stenit and all those
guys i think that's important to point
out this big time he's not some guy
wandering around this guy's brief to get
the highest security clearances he got
briefed on that he said they are
actively
running models
i'm not saying they're going to do it
but i'm saying you look at the spectrum
of things that nothing should be off the
table guys in the pentagon in the
national security apparatus are running
scenarios
he said it scenarios where you're going
to have a first strike tactical nuke and
you're going to have american combat
troops is this are the russians do they
want the ukraine for them to annex that
or something i know he annexed crimea or
they ukraine was very close to russia
with this fear of sphere of influence
they'd actually say eastern ukraine they
would actually argue as part of russia
doesn't ukraine just mean borderlands
yes that's that's what i was told when i
was in ukraine against borderlands
that's what they called it the ukraine
now the people of ukraine say drop the
the and just call it ukraine because
we're a country
they changed the spelling of kiev too
and then there was a lot of uh us
intervention and a lot of non-profits
that got involved in ukraine and there
was a revolution that was orchestrated
and that of course turned ukraine from
being corrupted by russia to being
corrupted by the european and nato side
and now there's still corruption in
ukraine because the revolution was all
based on corruption that corruption has
still continued to this day and some
people would argue was even made worse
by this larger transition quote
revolution
biden just counted look he had the
four-hour meeting with washi beforehand
he said you know in on the stage he said
oh we're gonna we're gonna defend taiwan
he had the four-hour meeting never
mention the wuhan you look at the two
readouts you look at the beijing readout
you look at the u.s readout not one
mentioned in four hours of the wuhan lab
of the ccp virus not one second to
mention he kowtowed they and he came out
and said oh we're a firm believer in the
one china policy the taiwan's a a region
of uh
of of china and eventually will be
united we believe in the we have the one
china policy he cow towed he's gutless
in
china and now he's trying to show his
commander-in-chief bravado in against
russia in the ukraine this is another
disaster it's somewhat it's that
insecure bully on the playground who's
like i'm gonna prove i'm tough by
picking on a little kid where's corn pop
when we need him
it's funny i mean look obama called uh
called russia a regional power remember
that yeah well they
they were a regional power that's what
they are but you know they aspire to be
a world power like they used to be but
they're not because
did i mention that the economy is the
size of new york state and they're in a
demographic death spiral when obama said
this it was seen as a slight yes you
know he was disparaging
because he knew putin wanted to bring
back the soviet union that power and he
couldn't and he was you know he was
basically being like look at us with the
big dogs and here's the regional power
russia should be our ally in breaking up
this this uh this iran pakistan uh
turkey
uh run by the ccp
trying to consolidate uh the uh the
eurasian land mass they should be an
ally we have forced them right and like
i said they're not good guys they're not
good guys but the enemy of my enemy is
my friend and they could have been the
enemy of our enemy which is the chinese
conference i don't i don't like that you
know that the idea but i do i i do think
it's fair to say the end of man the
enemy of my enemy can certainly work how
to work out an agreement with me in
dealing with our mutual how do we win
the world we wouldn't world war ii with
joseph stalin and if we hadn't had this
there was russians to take 25 chameleon
combat casualties we were never defeated
hitler and mussolini in the time we it
took to to to uh to destroy him but
remember but just for your audience
today's the 80th commemoration of pearl
harbor
franklin roosevelt went i think tomorrow
technically and declared war that date
that lives in infamy declared war
tomorrow 80 years ago on the imperia on
the empire of japan he did not declare
war on nazi germany or the the italian
fascist hitler declared war on us the
next day yeah because he had a secret
treaty and he thought we were weak he
thought we were all talking no action
meanwhile we were building nuclear
weapons and sending lots of money and
weapons to the british but they were
they were they were also working on
nukes too weren't they we just beat them
to it i mean they they were developing
very very close that's why they had the
heavy water in norway yeah that's why
and then
and the russians did as well so the
russians took their scientists i believe
they experimented they veered away from
nuclear research into the vr to rocket
research so that they could start
hitting the cruise missile and then
because of that they didn't get the
nukes in time bad decision but they
would have yeah because the the
blitzkrieg was that the zeppelins over
over london was that what it was yes so
if they had if they had gravity bombs
and if they focused on gravity bomb
research instead of cruise missiles they
were wiped out and like to tell senator
wicker the last time the first and only
time tactical nukes were
ever used
is in is it after the end of a three and
a half year that one of the bloodiest
wars ever had in the pacific right
because the japanese would not surrender
the kids and yet he's he's sitting there
with the pentagon think about it they
are running scenarios tonight as we talk
about putting combat inserting combat
troops i'm not going to say they're
doing it but they're thinking about it
they're not taking it off the table so
they're thinking now and modeling combat
troops to join nato and this eu army
right this eu military thing that the
french are trying to put together
in the ukraine and they're modeling
tactical nuclear strikes i did a lot of
research on modern nuclear weapons for
this segment i was actually doing with
discovery uh like you know this
discovery networks and uh i gotta say
like it was shocking how little people
who are like millennials for instance
understand the rapid technological
advancement in nuclear weapons
capability the the difference and i will
say this again between what we used in
world war ii that was a gravity bomb
what that means is it was a big bomb we
dropped it out of a plane since then
we've created intercontinental ballistic
missiles
multiple independently targeted reentry
vehicles carrying 12 warheads with 1
250 times the explosive power and you
know what else i learned did you know
the radiation is on purpose yes when a
nuclear bomb goes off and it radiates an
area that's intentional yes there's
actually russian nuclear bombs that do
not irradiate areas and the u.s has
similar ones too i was when we were
doing this research we looked at the
simulation of which kind of weapon used
by which country what would the level of
devastation be the initial incendiary
wave the the sonic the the shock wave
and the radioactive uh area and and
and what they do is i think the new york
times did this it was over manhattan
what would happen in manhattan and you
would pick like i'll use the you know
the russian whatever missile and it
shows a wave of fire just incendiary
wipes out from from from river to river
in new york but there's also lower uh
kiloton bombs that heavily irradiate the
area that when we talk about nukes
people need to understand this a nuclear
strike on russia could mean a lot of
things it could mean destroying that
area for hundreds of years and and it's
not just nuclear weapons that we have to
worry about since of course vladimir
putin even hinted at
biological weapons natural disaster
weapons and also artificial intelligence
weapons as of course vladimir putin on
the world stage a couple years ago came
out and said
artificial intelligence is going to be a
lot more powerful and lethal than
nuclear weapons himself he also said
that the country that leads the world in
the development of artificial
intelligence will be the ruler of the
world so these are the types of
situations that we're dealing with that
is even far more complex than nuclear
weapons which on the base level are
we're just beginning i'm no error i'm no
eric schmidt fan but the paper they put
up for the defense department a year ago
they came out with this book with
kissinger recently but the paper they
came up with a year ago said the exact
same thing said that there's an arms
race now on on ai and a i will ai will
be the future there's already all types
of weapons that you can see the future
if you have a smart enough
artificial intelligence that can
calculate probabilities and variables in
in the proper way looking at all the
data from social media they can they can
predict things i would imagine it would
be able to control drones turn them
around drop bombs on their other targets
missiles one let's talk about biological
weapons look what came out of wuhan we
know
was part of the pla's ccp's biological
weapons program okay that was being
researched at the time so you could have
all types of biological weapons
ukraine
is a scab you don't want to pick okay
because there's going to be a lot of pus
coming out of there i want i want to
point out an easy way for people to
understand the power of artificial
intelligence take a look at what they're
talking about with self-driving cars you
know i've got a tesla i could sit down
at it you pull the thing down twice the
car drives itself now what they're
talking about is we're not going to need
like you know the road signs we have and
all these things we don't need them
you're not going to need any road signs
because the cars talk to each other so
when two cars are coming at each other
you don't need you don't need lanes the
cars just know how far apart to be and
once all cars are smart look at what
they can do and predict and how they can
move around now think about the
weaponization capabilities of that you
will they will be able to use social
media data communications technology to
predict exactly where someone will be
we've long joked and i know this is this
is meant to be silly that facebook knows
when you poop yeah they literally do
they there was an article talking about
how facebook can predict based on how
long you've been sitting in one place
when the last time you you got food was
that they know when you will go to the
bathroom and they predict that now
imagine you've got a military general oh
they can predict when you poop they can
also predict where you'll be when you'll
be there they can effectively see the
future and then they can just say drop a
hellfire missile and you know what we
got an 87 chance of him actually being
there that's going to be the future of
ai warfare it will be terrifying thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time